[Laughter]  [Music]  i'm honestly not sure if that was a man  either i'm not saying that to be funny i  really don't know and i believe in the  biological differences between the sexes  but i'll admit that sometimes male  feminists can test my faith in that idea  and uh and yet again we get the the men  should have an opinion on ex-subject  thing you know to be a feminist man is  to be a neutered man a controlled man a  man shorn of personality and identity a  baby-faced ball-less simpering eunuch  this after all is the the objective of  feminism to destroy men destroy manhood  male feminists are the utopian ideal of  manhood according to feminism because  they are manhood without manhood they  are the absence of man or they're they  are a void they meant a monstrosity a  disgrace an embarrassment to their  fathers and their ancestors  other than that you know male feminism  is great